[Music]
i love central america when i was a
little kid i had a little club i was
jealous of my older brother for being in
boy scouts or cub scouts i guess because
i was even that was that young that i'd
started a central american club years
later i got to go to costa rica i had
been fascinated by it because of nash i
loved national geographic i loved
animals i and for some reason the
coolest ones seemed to live in costa
rica so years later when i got to go
there um i
had a day there with my friend james
duffy uh
supporter of the show and our lives
and hopefully he's listening he doesn't
support us no financially oh no no or
the show emotionally emotionally yes
that's right he's not our benefactor no
but i got to go there with james and a
bunch of other friends and um i think it
was the best day of my life was the day
that i got to
interact with monkeys i think they were
spider monkeys
i
don't know if i've ever really been
happier and again i don't think these
are things you're supposed to do i don't
think it's good for the monkeys but um
god it was a day i'll never forget my
point is i love monkeys you should seek
out monkeys more often i know it was
that great of it i know i've seen
footage of that day and i've never seen
you happier yeah i was like
you were like a pig and [ __ ] yeah i was
like a maniacal little kid
like happy maniacal yeah
good one that's right okay well speaking
of good maniacal here's the show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your often maniacally happy host justin
long life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is um
my brother christian who also you like
monkeys uh is it fair to say are they
not your favorite animal who doesn't
like
well they're so cute well i don't
crave um that experience that you had
you don't you i'm i'm sure i would enjoy
it but you would do it you'd welcome it
i'd be a little oh yeah apprehensive
well this now is
because i don't know what if they would
potentially hurt me right i mean these
were little it's true and with many
primates they could they could i mean
they're a little unpredictable yes yeah
um well these guys i would be i would
probably end up doing it if i got talked
into it but i wouldn't be
uh there'd be part of me that was
apprehensive uh until i i know what you
mean and i'm sure i was the same way
because these are there's something
about looking into the eyes of a monkey
they they they're just they just seem so
human in their hands i mean the way they
grasp
there is something
momentarily there was i remember i'm
trying to put myself back there
momentarily unsettling about it because
they do have such human
features and and
appendages
that it almost feels like they could do
so and they're wild they're feral
they're like so it's like if a little
hairy person like just jumped on your
head
you know you'd be like i wouldn't like
it yeah i know i know so there is a
moment of like adjustment like oh wait a
minute are they gonna like
rip out my you know
eyeball all of a sudden they're just
gonna like reach down and like smack me
in the face which would have been cute
but but it with a larger primate like a
chimpanzee
um
or chimpanzee oh i said oh i said
chimpanzee you say chimpanzee no you
just said japan chimpanzees oh i did
yeah oh uh i i that was a mistake
i didn't mean to um but anyway like that
they are capable of real i heard once
that that a it was either chimpanzee or
gorilla could palm
paul i knew you're
two coconuts and i just hold them out on
either side of itself like stretch out
its arms and
and crush them with both of them in one
move uh that seems difficult imagine
they're strong oh my god gorillas are
pound for pound for pound the strongest
animal in the world and they only eat
vegetables pretty cool back to chimps
why are we talking about chimps i will
tell you because
i'm so excited to do this it's going to
take me a while to find my way to
introduce her because
i think this i think this is for by far
our most distinguished guest well at
least the one the most distinguished to
me
the one i'm most excited about
and uh the one i can't believe agreed to
do the show uh our guest today is the
distinguished uh the legendary dr jane
goodall she's a dame she's our first
dame oh yes i actually didn't know that
but it's in no way surprising judy dench
has not returned our calls no i bet we
could get helen mirren you know why
because we know her son
we could yeah we should ask rito oh my
god anyway but it's not about you no no
no we let's be satisfied with one day at
a time yeah one day a year that's a
pretty good dame quotient uh jane
goodall is
like you said a legend she is the
world's foremost expert on chimpanzees
um she's a brilliant anthropologist and
primatologist and
we are i second your um excitement about
having her on the show it's what a what
a coup
we got her to do it it's monkey-like
exuberance it's it's and i'm saying that
very specifically it's the similar
exuberance that i displayed the day i
got to play with monkeys it's like um
there should be a word for that um but
but yeah i was just thrilled and
um i had seen her documentary i've known
her since i was a kid i've not known her
personally but one of her i've known
ever since i was a kid i mean just
reading about her and her work and how
it's just important it can't be it can't
be overstated um
and so i'm gonna save a lot of it
because i you'll hear me i just
obviously i'm
i gush and i you can't help but gush
around her and she's well we'll talk
about it she also has a podcast of her
own among many other things that she
does she's one of the busiest human
beings on the planet
she uh it's called hopecast
and
she uh travels over 300 days a year of
course she hasn't in the last year but
if you watch this documentary about her
the most recent one is called the hope
it's it's on disney plus
not an ad but it's
really incredible uh any any footage of
her i i'm sure most of you have probably
seen something of her and her work um
but this documentary was really moving
and
it's the most up-to-date one so that's
the one i'd recommend uh but it is
you'll see how much she works how much
she travels and how committed she is to
this cause and
what strong incredible convictions she
has so
we'll get into all of that uh now and i
feel like i should save some of the
save your gushing yeah okay all right
because you'll get plenty of it um after
this my my talk with the extraordinary
incredibly important dr jane goodall
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet
[Music]
ah finally yes first of all i'm so
grateful that you're here and that i i
know that tech frustration because i am
um probably more inept
than anyone at it so
i understand how i
thank you for sticking with it and uh
finding us i'm just sorry i kept you
waiting
not at all i i understand it and um and
uh please don't feel bad uh it's just
truly an honor so um your podcast is
called hopecast
and um
hopecast and i i
i that word seems to come up quite often
in your work uh and things about you
uh i just saw an incredible documentary
called the hope about about you and your
work um
what what what is it about after all the
things you've seen all the
many tragic things you've seen
what is it that that that
allows you to retain that hope well um
you know i've got i've got these four
reasons for hope
and one is the energy and commitment of
young people and they know the problems
and they're empowered to act
they're changing the world as we speak
you know our
roots into program in 68 countries
growing all the time
hundreds of thousands of groups
uh kindergarten through university and
everything in between and then
the uh brain we're coming up science
it's beginning to come up with ways that
can enable us to live in greater harmony
with nature
and we can use our brains to lead a
light ecological footprint
and thirdly the resilience of nature
give nature a chance and she'll take
over a place we've destroyed
and finally the indomitable human spirit
the people who tackle what seems
impossible and won't give up and
quite often succeed eventually even if
not in their lifetime and and is that
what continues this must be a strange
time for you i know i was talking to
sean about this
that you are it's incredible how much
you travel and um you're still yeah i've
heard over 300 days a year obviously not
now
is is
doing this we're doing this remotely via
zoom
how does that feel now to have been uh
experiencing this pandemic to have been
home and
to have been continuing your work but in
this this type of way wha what is what
is this like for you now well i missed a
contact with people i missed my friends
a virtual hug or a virtual toast isn't
the same as the real thing
and uh
trouble is it's much more exhausting
um you know it's non-stop zoom's just my
third zoom today
and there's
a long call after supper because for me
now it's six
and then um
you know the silver lining i've reached
millions more people in many many more
countries than i could have if i was
traveling so
just have to be
do what you have to do and this is
probably a silly question but but dr
goodall is it um
are you able to zoom with the with
chimps are chimps able to do something
like this no
no it's it's it's gonna be well if you
had if one of our sanctuary chimps was
on the other end
um they would be able to recognize
people on on a on a screen so oh they
would you could yeah
yeah theory you could do it but that
must be contact that you really miss the
chimps um
what was your earliest memory in terms
of gravitating towards animals uh the
way that you have and uh in in terms of
beginning that that passion that you
have i was born that way um my first
my first well it's not my memory but mum
told me that when i was one and a half
she came up to say good night she
finally got all these earthworms in my
bed with all the earth and everything
and she said jane you were looking so
intensely that it looked as though you
were wondering how do they move without
legs
but anyway being a wonderful mother a
supportive mother she didn't get mad at
all the mess she just said we better
take them into the garden because
they'll die if we leave them here wow
and wow so you were always even as a
just fascinated um wanting to know how
they
everything you could know about them you
wanted to do do you have pets did you
have um
were you just always around them were
you always exploring
well we we had there was always a dog in
my life and a cat
and then when i got older there were
guinea pigs and hamster
and we had rescue tortoises
that was about it but you know out in we
got a big garden here i'm actually in
the house where i grew up
and that's right you know the trees i
used to climb and
so i was out there watching swirls and
birds and insects i loved watching
insects right from the beginning i don't
know just was born that way
yeah why isn't that incredible and then
at what and your mother was also the one
that encouraged you that told you this
is a beautiful story that you talk about
how
she said you're gonna have to work a
little bit harder uh because women at
that time um
you know that wasn't a
path that was really possible for women
um could you talk about that and how uh
how she encouraged you to to set out on
that path
well it all began really when i read
tarzan aged 10.
i knew there wasn't a tarzan but i was
really jealous of his jade anyway
so that was when my dream began i will
grow up go to africa live with wild
animals and write books about them and
everybody laughed you know africa's far
away
you don't have we didn't have money and
of course it was during world war ii
so and you're just a girl
girls don't do that sort of thing back
then when i was 10
nobody was going out living with wild
animals and watching them nobody not
even men
so it was mum who said if you really
want this sort of thing you're going to
have to work really hard take advantage
of every opportunity and maybe if you
don't give up you find a way
so that's how she
encouraged me
by not
damping me down
it's incredible and and
and and then jane uh dr goodall how did
you come to know dr leakey who
um who invited you to go to africa for
the first time
no i was invited by a school friend
whose parents bought a farm in kenya
i had to save up money worked in a hotel
around the corner there
as a waitress until i'd saved enough
money i didn't go to university because
we couldn't afford it
and
so i got out stayed with my friend and
then somebody said jane if you're
interested in animals you should meet
louis leaky
so although i was very shy
i was so excited and i called up
and i said could i speak to dr leaky
and the voice said i'm leaky what do you
want he hated the telephone he was rude
so plucking up all my courage i said can
i come and talk to you about animals
anyway
he said yes and
i'd read everything i could and i think
he was impressed about what i did know
wasn't much to learn in those days
so he took me on
as his secretary to start with
so
i think gradually he realized i was the
person he'd been looking for
to go and study chimpanzees i would have
studied
mice anything to be out in a while
oh i wondered yeah i wondered what it
was about so it just happened to be
because he his it was that his focus at
the time
he he was searching for the fossilized
remains of early humans
and from a fossil you can tell a lot
about what the creature looked like and
how it moved from the muscle attachment
wear on their teeth gives you an idea of
the diet but behavior
doesn't fossilize so he thought well six
million years ago there was an ape-like
human-like common ancestor
to apes and us and if jane finds
behavior in chimps that similar or the
same behavior in humans today
maybe
it's come directly from that common
ancestor and that meant he could imagine
early humans behaving
kissing embracing holding hands
attacking one another swaggering using
tools hunting you know
yes and it's your work that was
groundbreaking of course at the time and
and we have now just come to we i've
grown up in a time where that has been
been accepted that uh that behavior is
so human-like but but you describe it as
being something that we had um
we were possessive over that kind of
behavior of that kind of behavior um
using tools expressing affection um
what are your recollections of
like when you first
saw it when you first saw that kind of
behavior and
and and how did you
how did you find the chimpanzees when
you set out when you went to gambi for
the first time how did you
find yourself uh and how were you able
to ingratiate yourself
well
first of all when i first got there i
was made to take
somebody with me i wasn't allowed to go
up in the mountains alone
and the chimps ran away and ran away ran
away and i thought well if i could be by
myself
it might be better so eventually they
thought i was a bit crazy but
the authorities british back then was
you know last crumbling outpost of the
british empire
angonica it was then
um so they let me go
on my own as long as i told them roughly
where i was going
and
one chimp began to lose his fear of me
david greybeard he's up
up there somewhere next to the elephant
and uh
david greybeard
on this one day four months into my
study i only had six months money
and there he was using a tool and making
tools which at that time
science said that only humans use and
make tools so that was the breakthrough
and dr goodall did you have were you
capturing the camera
that's cool
yeah well i prefer if you called me dr
long um no uh
okay jane thank you um
so you're four months in are you
beginning to again that word hope are
you beginning to lose hope how do you
hold on to the hope of maybe
um
that that you may be able to get close
enough to them after four months well i
knew given time that i could just as i
always had with any animal
did i have time i was getting
you know really
anxious
and i think you know but for the first
four months my mother was there
did you know that my mother
the british authorities refused for me
to be alone i had to bring some other
white woman with me and mom volunteered
so she
boosted my morale you know she
she pointed out that from this peak i
discovered with my binoculars i was
actually learning even though it wasn't
exciting i was learning about their
calls the food they eat the kind of way
they go around alone or little groups
and they all gather together when
there's a good food learning about their
calls
and so she boosted my morale i'm sure
were you was she fearful were you
fearful was there ever a sense of
trepidation that
perhaps if you got too close they might
um
they might attack you no because they
were running away
right
they're very conservative they've never
seen a white ape before
right
and so when dr when dr greybeard when
david graybeard he hasn't i don't think
gotten his doctorate but but when he um
when he was finally
comfortable enough with you um
how was was how close were you able to
get to him and and then how long did it
take for others to see his to recognize
his behavior and and understand that you
were safe
well when i saw him fishing for termites
the tools
four months in
i still couldn't get close to him at all
um
but i could get closer than the others
and he didn't run when he saw me
so i i would say
six seven months
i could begin to get you know
30 feet or something like that
and he did help because if he was in a
group
with others ready to run
and he just sat there they sort of
looked from him to me
i suppose they thought well she can't be
so scary after all
yeah thief
yeah and then he came into my camp and
stole bananas
that was the beginning of the banana
offering
oh
oh so this is um now you have leverage
yep that's right it's like i always
think it's rather like the
anthropologists who used to go
to uncontacted tribes and lay out beads
and things so
mindless bananas
which you wouldn't do today it's not
done but back then i think all the
field studies use that sort of method
now dr goodall why why is it not done
today they just don't want to um
it's just a matter of getting too close
or or well the chimps shouldn't become
comfortable with humans
well we now know that they can catch our
diseases
and we can catch theirs
and
you know it does interfere with their
behavior obviously if they're coming to
a new food but as i was interested in
the difference between individuals
eventually all the individuals had the
same
law of bananas so
it didn't matter to me
uh yes and and and then how long did you
stay that first time and and once your
mother left um was at that point was
there ever any sense of
i don't know why i'm hung up on this but
was there a sense of fear that you're
now
truly by yourself
no it was wonderful i mean i missed mum
but being on my own is something i've
always loved and
being on my own there was a cook we had
a cook dominic
and when mum left leaky sent his very
trusted boat driver from lake victoria
and he was you know
stately wise
wonderful man her son
mom didn't mind leaving when she knew he
was coming uh
wow and and uh she must have been very
proud of you she must have sounds like
she was a remarkable person too she was
amazing there she is
yes jane's
pointing right behind her um i love that
you're still in the house that you
grew up and this is really beautiful
yep um
it's a family house my sister lives here
permanently with her family
so you've had people around during this
quarantine you it's not been an
isolating experience no
oh good okay i wouldn't have minded
no
yeah well that's how you describe your
time uh with the chimpanzees in gamba
you describe it as it sounds idyllic i
mean it sounds also very quite spiritual
the way you were able to commune with
nature and you compare it to being in
certain cathedrals yeah um
and and was there that sense that um
when you go back there do you are you
immediately filled with that sense of
spiritual connectivity
yeah as soon as i'm on my own in the
forest it doesn't have to be gumby
any
any wild nature it's just that spiritual
connection with
whatever
spiritual power is there
i bet and is were you raised with that
uh chain were you raised with the
spirituality in any sort of
judeo-christian
yeah my grandfather who i never met
who
clearly was wonderful my mother's father
um he was a congregational minister
so
we weren't particularly religious but
you know we went to church sometimes
certainly at christmas and easter
and um mum was very wise and she used to
say to me you know
you were born into a christian family so
you worship god but you might have been
born
in egypt then you'd probably be a muslim
you'd worship allah or you might have
been born
um you know in israel and then you'd
have
whatever they had jehovah or whoever
so she said there can only be one
god whatever name
he or she is called or whatever that
spiritual entity is
so right from the beginning she taught
me this
uh you know very very wise way of
just thinking beyond the name of the
religion and if you look at the basic
root of all the major religions every
single one
they have the same golden rule due to
others as you would have them do to you
that runs right through everyone jainism
buddhism a whole lot life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
your connection with chimpanzees how has
that changed your the way you connect
with humans
i think it's helped me understand humans
a bit better you know what we have
brought with us from that ancient
ape-like human-like common ancestor
but you know one day i was out in the
forest
just alone
and there was some chimps feeding high
in the tree
and i just have this strong feeling that
you know we we put words into everything
and so we talk about having a soul
and we talk about spirituality and this
and the other and i thought well
it seems to me that there's a spark
of
life a spark of of
a sort of spark of spirit
in every animal in
every tree
and in us
and in us we call it soul
so i thought well if if i have a soul
i hope so if i have a soul probably a
chimpanzee has a soul
and
we have a gambi
a very beautiful waterfall well several
but this one falls 80 feet
and over the years and years and years
it's won a groove in the solid rock
and so as the water plunges 80 feet down
into this shallow stream
makes a roaring sound
and the water displaces the air so
there's always a breeze and the vines at
the side of this gorgeous
channel are swaying
and when the chimps approach not always
but often
the males start hair bristling
and they get
normally they avoid the water it's only
about that deep they stamp upright in it
from side to side they bend down they
pick rocks they may
then sometimes climb up the vines beside
the fall push out in the spray
and then at the end you see them sitting
on a rock
looking up
what is this
stuff it's always coming
it's always going but it's always here
and i think if chimps had words
if they could actually share the
emotions and discuss them like we can
that might have led to an early
animistic religion you know the worship
of some stars
sure
wow but you can see them you can see
them moved and wow that is uh
that's wow like they they share our
sense of wonder and all wonder
god to witness that what
what what does that feel like to you to
describe that to somebody who is i'm in
awe of just the second-hand version of
it but um
what what is that like the first time
that you saw that human behavior the
first time that you made that connection
that um
they're not only are is their dna so
closely related but their behavior and
the way they show affection what what
did that feel like jane to to witness
that firsthand
well it was all magic you know
yeah right at the beginning i was so
intent on collecting data
that i didn't relax enough to feel the
wonder of the magic of what i was
actually seeing but then
as as
you know as i began to learn more the
chimps relaxed
then i had time to sit back and have
these
thoughts mystical almost
i bet
i bet and and
time and uh the there must the serenity
that
and you were for the most part on your
own so so
yeah it must have been meditative and
um
when do you think you'll be able to go
back there and experience that again
well it's not the same now
it's not the same zombie that it was
you know this
tourists coming and
you know being having a slightly funny
knee
i can't climb high up in the hill well i
could but it would be kind of silly
because
i if the knee went funny i might slip
and then i'd give everybody such
problems
bring me down again
so
i can only see the chimps if they're low
and that's when they'll be surrounded
with tourists
no sorry
so
and zombie for me getting in the forest
is wonderful
but it's just it's just different it's
wonderful for people who've never been
there before
they get the most amazing experiences
and say it was one of the best times of
their life
but then i've been so lucky to know it
when it was
mine
it was really lucky
i bet yes yeah well
um
and how did your relationship with uh
that first chimpanzee david greybeard um
the one that you first were able to make
contact with how did that relationship
evolve what was that process like oh
well he was such a character
he was uh
he was a born leader he wasn't the top
ranking male
but when he moved off others liked to
follow him he was very quick to reassure
a frightened youngster or female they'd
come running up to him
if they were frightened of some
aggressive male or something and he'd
hug them or pat them
and he was very wise he was also very
very
determined and if he didn't get his
bananas
he'd come into the tent
pull it apart
once it was the worst time
behind the camp there's quite a steep a
hill going up to a ridge between valleys
um
it's quite tall anyway i was climbing up
there
and right at the top
i met david
and he
janus and then camp i won't get a banana
so he took my wrist
there's nothing like oh my god he went
quite fast and i thought you know any
minute i'm going to trip and if i fall
on top of him
lovely though he is he'll be frightened
so he's so much stronger than me but
fortunately i managed to keep on my feet
but then oh my god
when we got to the camp um i was on my
own up there
but we
had uh bought by then we'd had boxes
made at chimps it wasn't free for all
and we have to go inside the building
and unloosen a latch and then the box
would fall open
and the chimp could take the bananas
well he went to where the bananas came
out
and held me
well i couldn't give him the bananas
without
and then he began to get angry and you
don't want david greybeard angry i think
oh my god what happened i think somebody
arrived thank goodness
i was able to get the bananas out that's
incredible
um
and it's def that's incredible and did
you ever i mean that's an example of um
did you ever feel
threatened certainly maybe not by that
chimpanzee but by others were there
times where you felt yeah you gotten too
close yeah i mean frodo
he's oh he disappeared because he's
rubberdog but he was a bully bullied
other chimps bullied humans had a
research station by then
um he used to go out of his way to
charge us and push us over or
they need to stamp on us
but uh the two people he did it to most
were me
because i wasn't there all the time by
then i went away and came back so i
think every time i went back he had to
prove all over again that he was
dominant which is regardless i mean
right but
and then our videographer
and both of us
have been in situations where had he
done his normal thing
pushing
we would have died because of the edge
of a precipice or something like that
and on those occasions he didn't do it
really so he knew that the limits he
knew he certainly didn't want to kill
you no he was just showing off
showing off
proving he's dominant you know
and jane while that's happening do you
have to just kind of go with it you you
can't certainly fight back i mean do you
just be ridiculous no
yeah
wow what and what other chimps uh like
david greybeard would they be able to um
protect you or or no because he is in
that order they wouldn't want to i mean
i didn't try and be part of the the
group i wanted to be an observer
yeah
yeah and and
when did you make um
actual
physical contact what was that like was
did was that a very gradual thing and
and um
how did that feel to actually actually
reach out and be able to touch them
well
uh
very few did i actually touch
david gravian first time he took a
banana from my hand that was magic
and i could groom him
and i could groom one or two of the
others flow and have family
but most of them i didn't touch
but
how do you um
how do you discover those boundaries
like with flo and her family uh
what is that process like i'm sure it's
very gradual but but what was it like to
actually get to that point where you
could
you could groom them
well i think the most
after grooming david the most wonderful
experience was flo her infant flint was
about
five months just tottering you know
they develop slowly like children
and
he was looking at me i was sitting on
the ground
and he came towards me and flo was bit
worried still
she had her hand around his tummy but
she let him come
she had a little pouting face which is a
bit nervous
he came right up
looking up with those big big eyes
into mine and he reached out and touched
my nose and that was
that was absolute magic
absolute magic one that she trusted me
enough
and two to have that
that wonder who is she
you know i don't know have you seen that
recent
um movie that's getting so much acclaim
my octopus teacher
i know i've yet to see it i've heard so
much about it because i talked to the
guy craig foster and
he told me that he had much that same
feeling when this octopus reached out
and stroked his face with one of her
arms
oh god yeah wow i now i really need to
see it um
so
when you have experiences like that that
are um
i mean they're moving just to hear about
uh
how then does it feel um
cutting several decades later to
when you began your work as an activist
when you um
when you begin to discover
exactly what's happening with research
chimps and
and uh the work that needs to be done in
terms of deforestation
how does it feel to see chimps in in
those conditions then and um and was it
was it just being moved was it being
moved by their plight having seen them
that encouraged you to kind of break out
of your comfort zone in terms of
not like you say not really being
the most social person and being a bit
shy uh did you feel then
pushed to do that yeah it was
it was a conference that i helped put
together in 1986
and then there were i think it was six
or seven other
field sites across africa
and so we decided to put together a
conference to bring the chief
researchers together for the first time
mainly to
ask you know does chimp behavior differ
in different environments
uh is there something like culture where
behaviors pass from one generation to
the next but we had a session on
conservation
and the session on conditions
in
circus lab that sort of thing
and
the shock of seeing the extent of
deforestation in africa
and chimpanzees being hunted for bush
meat
and that sort of thing and then even
worse really
was seeing our closest living relatives
who can live 60 years
in five foot by five foot cages in
medical research labs that was
so awful and
worst of all
when i left that conference i was
different i just knew i had to do
something i had no idea what to do like
having a clue
but first of all
i knew i wanted to help the lab gyms
i knew i had to go into a lab because
you need to see with your own eyes to
really talk
meaningfully and i think it was one of
the hardest things i've ever ever had to
do
i want to see these
amazing beings in five foot by five foot
cages alone
you describe um it's very powerful in
the documentary you describe
crying under your surgical mask um
just weeping and uh one of the chimps i
think you'd say he's been there for 15
years been isolated in this in this cage
for 15 years reach reaches out and um
wipes away
wipes
which probably made you cry even more
yes of course
yeah anyway finally it's a long battle
with many people joining that there are
no more chimps in american research labs
now
it's incredible the way you've been able
to reach people and you talk about
you talk about that uh how how best to
do activism
um and i thought this was especially in
light of
the way a lot of people do it now with
social media there's so much anger
there's so much division uh there's so
much arguing um could you talk a little
bit about
what you found to be the most productive
way
to uh to to be an activist and and to
really help these peop
chimpanzees but also the people who live
among them
well
um the lab situation was one where i
just sat down
and instead of being angry with the
people doing that research
i just showed pictures of the gombi
chimps talked about their behavior their
personality
and it came from within i think people
need to change from within
africa
well i
got together some money
and visited six different
range countries where chimps were being
studied
i learned a lot about
what
problems that
chimps were facing
but at the same time i learned about the
problems faced by so many of the african
people you know the crippling poverty
the lack of health and education
the degradation of the land human
populations growing
and then i flew over the tiny gombe
national pockets only 35 square
kilometers
and it had been part of this great
equatorial forest built when i arrived
in 1960 and it was the same in 1970
and then it began to change
and when i flew over gambian
towards the end of the 1980s
it was this tiny island of forest and
all around as far as you could see bare
hills
and
that's when it hit me these people
it's too many of them for the lands to
support
they're too poor to buy food elsewhere
the farmland is overused and infertile
they are struggling to survive
if we don't help them find ways of
making a living without destroying the
environment by cutting the trees because
they have to grow more food
they have to cut the trees
or make money from charcoal
so that's when
the jungle institute takari take care
takari program began
very holistic
going into the 12th villages around
zombie
with not arrogant white people but
locally selected africans who they knew
who went in and listened to the people
and asked them what what can we do to
help
and that's how takari began and it's now
in 104 villages throughout all of the
chimp range
and the people have become our partners
in conservation life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
it was roots and shoots born of a
similar idea of wanting to educate the
next generation and
yeah allow them to you know yeah because
i started the career to curry well
similar programs in six other african
countries so you have to raise money
right and raise money to keep the
research going
and to keep by then there were
institutes that
needed help
and so i was traveling around the world
and meeting so many young people who
seem to have lost hope
and they were either angry
or they were
deeply depressed
or they were just apathetic didn't seem
to care
and when i asked them
well we feel like this because you've
compromised our future and there's
nothing we can do about it
well we have compromised their future
haven't we
i mean you hear uh we haven't inherited
this planet from our ancestors we
borrowed it from our children when you
borrow you pay back we've been
not borrowing stealing
but
not too late to do something about it
that's where they were wrong and that's
where roots and shoots began
and and what what emboldened you to
push forward with that message i mean
how
again how did you not lose your hope
what what encouraged you um in i know
you talked about the four points um
but in that moment what was it that
what what what was the best way to show
people that hope was possible well it
actually began when 12 high school
students
from eight schools in dar es salaam
capital of tanzania they came to my
house
and they were concerned about all kind
of different problems you know
environmental but also social like the
street children cruelty to spray dogs
they have different problems
and anyway i told them to go and find
their friends who felt the same
and we had a meeting of about 30 i
suppose
and that's when roots and chutes was
born main message every single one of us
makes an impact every single day of some
sort
and
we decided that every group and the
roots and shoots would work with clubs
or groups in different schools
they would they would choose we wouldn't
tell them they would choose a project
help people project help animals project
help the environment
and because they get to choose
and you listen to them they're empowered
and they roll up their sleeves and they
get out work with passion it's all about
taking action
and if they choose what to do they're
passionate about it
whereas if somebody comes in and says
you will do this or you will do that and
we're going to do that sometimes they
just don't care
it doesn't come from within
yeah now we're in 68 countries
with members from kindergarten
university everything in between and
more and more adults forming groups now
like the staff of the big corporation
well that's the other remarkable thing
is that you were able to reach out to
and and you took a lot of flack for it
um reaching out to
big corporations that
um
might might have seemed like it was
against your interests um
to reach out to oil companies and
uh but you were able to use those
relationships to then uh foster and
promote
the the more important message a greater
message um how would you encourage
people to do that to reach out to those
that they disagree with now and um
how is social media play a part in that
and and how can it hinder that well
first of all i wouldn't take money from
all the oil companies no it's one it has
to be one that's actually trying to do
it better
and the one we started with was conoco
before it
before it amalgamated with well what is
it now phillips
it was a very very forward thinking i
mean i
i don't think there's another oil
company that's as forward thinking as
they were unfortunately it cost more
and uh they
they didn't survive on their own but
uh
so
basically i
was offered this opportunity to get
money from them to start our sanctuary
in congo
and so i thought it all through and i
thought well you know i'm
buying oil i mean i'm paying for planes
cars
electricity everything
so how hypocritical
to pay money
but refuse to take money from them
because it might make them look better
and all these
you know
these people who are so
militant
they were i was attacked
i was attacked for sitting down and
talking to the people in the medical
research level if you don't talk to
people how can you ever expect them to
change
now you know one lovely thing about
roots and shoot they become very
passionate
and they're changing their parents and
their grandparents and some of them
are you know the head of a lab or a ceo
of a big company or in government
are we seeing those changes with kids
that must give you even more hope and
and fill you with uh
it must make you so happy i can only
imagine
um
jane beyond giving money now to these
causes to um
roots and shoots and janet goodall
institute um what what can people do to
help you talked about the choices that
everyone makes every day um is it is it
as simple as uh just examining the
choices that you make and being more
conscientious of their impact if
everybody made ethical choices in what
they buy i mean did it on the
environment was it cruel to animals is
it cheap because of child slave labor
you know is this equitable
um
if everybody made those choices
the world would be so much better but
that can never happen until we alleviate
poverty because when you're really poor
you buy the cheapest because that's how
only way to survive
you know we've got to alleviate poverty
we've got to reduce our unsustainable
lives lifestyle
i mean mine's unsustainable and i'm sure
yours is too
i yes in many ways i do my best but i
know
that i'm
using up you know probably more than my
fair share of natural resources which
are finite
so the problem is
thinking that there can be unlimited
economic development on a planet with
finite natural resources and a growing
population
if we carry on with business as usual
something's got to go
and in terms of resources how to do that
how best to achieve that how to how to
put that uh mentality into practical
effect um where can people go what what
resources would you recommend
well
we're putting together a website that
has all this information on it but you
just have to get out there on the
internet it's all there
you know i mean one thing we can do
that truly will help the environment and
perhaps eat less or no meat
and dairy
and you know because
the factory farms where billions of
animals live in absolute misery i mean
they're cruel beyond dreams
they have to be fed
cleared areas to grow the grain fossil
fuel used to get the grain to the
animals the abattoir meat to the table
water so scarce in some places now with
climate change
lots used wasted
turning vegetable to animal protein
and finally they were producing methane
gas in their digestion
so
it's uh
and also it was our disrespect of
animals and nature that's led to this
pandemic
and to climate change and
the loss of
biodiversity
yeah
yeah that's um so that's a very good
place to start uh
eating less
hopefully eating none um something i
want to
implement in my life so uh thank you for
the reminder and um
i you know i could talk to you for hours
i know your time is is limited um i'm so
grateful for it i i just have a we do
like a lightning round chain like um
that we ask everybody the same kind of
quick
answer questions if you if you would
indulge me i'll then do my best
okay all right and i i
uh most apologize for the first one um
to be asking somebody as distinguished
as yourself this question um i'm
wondering what is your most commonly
used emoji if you use emojis i can't
believe i'm asking i don't but i don't
use them i took a long time to work out
why people were putting these peculiar
little red dots all over their emails so
i'm afraid i'm old still use words
no that's um
that makes sense uh uh i'm now imagining
what the chimpanzees what they would
think of those emojis and
because i know they communicate a lot
through their you know facial
gesture
gestures
i think that jane goodall is trying to
get somebody to do a chimp emoji but i'm
not sure but i wait oh really
okay and shane how how would a
chimpanzee communicate um i i i don't
that's something negative i don't do
that
okay so away with the question obvious
yeah okay but you know they can
obviously yeah they can learn up to 400
of the signs used by deaf people
oh my god and they can communicate not
just with their teacher but with each
other
and you get an amazing glimpse
into how the mind works differently from
others like
some of them love drawing and this young
chimp had
been learning sign language she was five
years old i think she loved
drawing
and she used to cover the page make nice
circles and everything on this occasion
she got this piece of paper and her
teacher was the other side of the table
and she went like this
with the
so that she handed it to the teacher and
teacher can you finish it signed can you
finish
and she
looked at it and handed it back and said
finished signed finished so the teacher
thought and said what is it
do you know what she said
it's a ball
we draw a ball like that she drew the
movement bouncing
oh
my god yeah isn't that
oh
that they connected those thoughts
that's
it
unbelievably advanced yeah oh my god
and where was this gym where did you f
is there different is there a different
level of um
ability uh depending on where a chimp
comes from depending on the the
environment in which they're raised or
that well that can make a difference
yeah i mean you won't get a wild chimp
doing that
but these were chimps in a
sign language program
about
20 30 years ago now
and they were being taught sign language
which actually is a way of enriching
their lives into their captive
they like
lots of stimulation otherwise they get
bored
that was the worst thing about the lab
chimps in this tiny cage with nothing
nothing nothing
so i persuaded the lab to let us send in
a young man
a very tough young man to survive it and
he designed enrichment activities
like putting food in a tube and they
weren't they got sticks they could push
it out that sort of thing
to kind of mimic the way they retrieved
termites
he thought of all kinds of things for
them to play with
and branches so they could pull off and
eat the leaves anything to alleviate
boredom and that's something we
intrigued we have introduced into zoos
around the world now
every good
enrichment
oh wow it's incredible that um
the work you've done how many lives
you've enriched um
uh
through that work that's incredible i i
it must have taken everything in you to
not when you saw that those conditions
and these animals you loved being
treated like it must have
been so difficult to withhold your anger
and to to not express anger toward these
people that were
yeah like that but you know anger
doesn't get you anywhere
yeah
i mean i think there's a place for it
sometimes just to wake people up
but once you've woken them up then you
have to well that's my way anyway
you have to reach them you have to talk
to them to the heart yeah
stories
stories
yeah personal stories and that's how you
were able to reach uh i mean it took a
long time but you did it the nih
uh you know it's funny i just being with
you just through zoom i can feel um
a great deal of uh you have a great deal
of
such magnetism such uh
empathy gift i can't take credit for it
that's the way no i um
well i i'd like to thank
whoever your mom whoever you know
endowed you with that uh
and those chimpanzees who gave that to
you uh it's
been a gift to the world um
uh i'm sorry i i don't know how to make
a segue into these other these again
these are you can just rifle through
these um because i know we're running
out of time if we're not out of it
already um
a sport that you've really enjoyed jane
uh if you could be an athlete if
if you enjoyed athletics at all is there
one that you gravitate toward i've never
been really into sport
no
okay
um if you
okay
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life something that you've
really enjoyed maybe that you took with
you uh
on your travels
well it used to be chocolate
but i've been a vegan now for
quite some time about a year
and vegan chocolate is really very
particularly nice mostly
so i don't know okay but you know
luckily i don't care about
food oh you don't no it's not although i
do have to say that vegan food well
cooked
uh with a good chef there's nothing
better nothing
my whole life that's a good thing i love
your chimp lamp by the way
oh i was wondering
yes it's um
it's uh i i found it somewhere in a
you know i forget where um but i love
chimps and i love it
it's a sad sound it's what the young
ones do when they're being denied subtly
when they're four or five years old
oh wow
oh well now i'm going to hear that
differently so that the happy one is
you do it on the intake
[Laughter]
wow
and and what about uh fear how do they
express cream
ah just uh
wow
now with something like that
[Laughter]
now
now when you
witness that behavior how did you did
you just audio recorded it you would um
film them doing that
how did you record that
well i didn't start with i just recorded
it my brain
then when we started making films to the
geographic yeah
hugo yeah oh
camera and a recorder
wow wow well
i'm i'm most because i think i love the
sound of laughter the most how did you
um
how did you first discover that what do
you recall um your introduction to them
laughing yeah when they tickle each
other
[Laughter]
of course wow
makes sense um and uh
if if you uh what is your favorite fruit
i i know fruit is something that you get
yeah i love fruit i don't know i love
mangoes really good mangoes
and are really good but we don't get
really good bananas in america and
europe but in africa where they have a
village near us there's 25 different
kinds of banana
and some of those are fabulous they're
very sweet
um
you know that very smelly
yes tastes wonderful i've never had it i
will now per your recommendation
um try some durian uh and if you who
would you want to play i'm sure they are
going to make one if they haven't
already to play you uh an actress to
play you in in your biopic oh wait well
if you had your dress thought and
thought about this but i don't know and
you see the trouble is i don't have time
to watch
movies much
so i don't really know and i people
laugh and they said oh you just got to
be joking when i said that i wouldn't
recognize robert redford or something
like that and i said no because well i
don't
well
i know how much you travel i know how
much you're how much you work and that
makes sense to me i i i don't doubt that
um
yeah that makes sense when you were a
girl when you were growing up did you
watch was that something you enjoyed i
mean it was during the war uh we didn't
have tv
and we couldn't
couldn't afford the cinema
and mom saved up to take me i think i
was 11
um
and it was one of the first johnny wise
smaller movies that came
so she saved up to take me after about
15 minutes i began to cry loudly she had
to take me out say whatever matter i
said but that wasn't tarzan
you see in those days there were no tv
so it was
yes
children are deprived of that now so all
the books i read i had my own imaginary
people
do you prefer i know you said you've had
dogs uh do you prefer dogs or cats
as pets
as my teacher when i was a child
my teacher
oh
beautiful is that a lab it's a month
a month it's a mutt um
they're my favorites yeah
i
couldn't see them a little bit is that
your mom
yes oh yeah there he is
what was her name jane her net well
house welsh named mavanley but she was
known as van
and van maban nickname was
ah what a great
what a great tribute
um i i am so grateful to her and uh she
she just created the most beautiful
person i'm beyond grateful to you for
your time and your your work um thank
you
well thank you too i've really loved
talking to you
i hope we can meet in person
it would be an honor and and jane if
there's anything i can do
i'm dying to go uh work and and and see
one of your your
the roots and shoots um
[Music]
places that you've set up i'd like
anything i can do to help spread your
message because i think it is great the
most fruits and shoots spread to curry
spread jti
all helps a lot
yeah and um
shoots
anybody with a child can start roots and
shoot you don't have to be formal
you can just be two kids getting
together and saying we want to change
the world and so they decide what to do
we like them to register so that we can
share but it doesn't cost anything
okay good to know we'll um we'll talk
all about it yeah we'll i'll continue to
talk about it and um
i i will always be grateful to you for
the for this and all of your work well
thank you very much i love talking to
you and as i say we must meet in person
it would it would be my honor thank you
jane i look forward to it yeah me too
and say hello to the family and all the
earthworms outside
so
that happened oh my
yes it
it surely did
and i i'm ever so grateful that it did
she sounds like um i couldn't get this
out of my head and i don't know if
you'll remember this reference but she
sounds like
older wendy and hook
oh my gosh
kind of um in the animated wisdom no not
animated hook the robin williams oh no i
didn't get it
okay never mind
uh wendy wasn't that gwyneth paltrow no
um it wasn't where did paltrow could
play her i bet
we were talking about who should play
her yeah she could oh terry mulligan
carrie mullen's got because she has such
wisdom herself and like this i bet
you know what i changed my answer carrie
mulligan should play but um
yeah what wisdom there's she also to me
and i hope this doesn't sound
insulting i oh i can't wait well i mean
sometimes you love things that are
prefaced that way but um she
her voice to me it felt like of a wise
uh
sage like woodland creature in in a
children's
fairy tale and some sort of like wind in
the willows yes one of the willows yeah
yeah like um
some sort of
map like a
like a sage mouse yeah like um yeah
she's very like about peter rabbit like
that mm-hmm um what are the beatrix
pockets
she's she's a beast potter character
she's
yeah now that sounds excellent not a
character but but a good but i know
those characters were wise she's so why
i mean look if at this point in the show
people think i'm
capable of disrespecting her oh my god
you haven't been paying attention you
went from being you went from being
nervous and like stammery in the
beginning i was yeah that's okay i mean
it's jane goodall
you were like went from nervous to
stammering to being like
emotional and weepy for the rest of it i
it got a little weird i got um
i and i can't explain it i meant
everything i said there really is
something magnetic about her about her
presence about her she's like magical
she is
she's magic she's the most magical
person i've ever met but she
talks about other things and experiences
in people as magical yeah she uses
language like that you're right but she
must have been endowed with something
there's something about her and they
talk about this in the documentary how
when she'd visit these research
facilities where these chimps were being
kept in horrible conditions and anytime
she'd visit anywhere with the chimp and
zoos or whatever they would gravitate
toward her there's something inside of
her like a light she seems like i was
born this way this is just this is just
how i am i think for her work to have
happened there had to have been some
sort of um she had to have had something
inside of her that allowed the first one
was dr uh dr greybeard david gravebeard
why do i keep giving him a doctorate i
did that on the show too dr graybeard
david gravey
david greybeard i know but like for
them to there must have been something
they were responding to like um
a calm something she was endowed with
also the patience it took
leading up to her interaction what was
it for six seven eight months
um until she had really close contact
with them i think that's what she said
um but what amazing i know
and and it
it takes someone who is not only willing
to be alone but is very comfortable
being alone i know to do something like
that
you know the patience all day for months
yeah trying to get closer to these
creatures and um i know and then the
fortitude i mean like talk about
starting trump there her sweet voice is
obvious and fun to listen to but it's
contrasted
in such a fascinating way with her tough
i know like tough as nails spirit when
you uh consider what she does now and
ever since the 80s when she kind of like
came out of not that she was in hiding
she was doing research as a but very
reclusive type work she was doing and
she kind of came out when she recognized
the impact she could have and
how much more she could do to help
protect these chimps that were
disappearing and she'd have to be like
to your point to be able to sit for that
many months in like solitude the
sacrifice that that takes to then go and
devote your life to be happy completely
public you know and travel over 300 days
a year give yourself up to that
those crowds and the you know she's just
not wired that way i mean it's there's
you're right like that it's that's
sacrifice it's an extra sacrifice
considering how comfortable she is being
alone and i think
um someone who is able to make that kind
of that level of sacrifice in my
estimation is
a saint i mean it's like
you know we were raised catholic and
there's a certain sense of of what it
takes to be a saint and you know you
hear you read about these figures that's
what we would always hear like mother
teresa and any sort of any martyr any
martyr yeah how is she not i know
saintly no i don't think that's really
an overstatement no
it might be an understatement
i know that she is has given up so much
and and for a singular passion and has
to the point where she is um
taught a whole generation of people not
only about chimpanzees and about the
need to protect the environment which
shouldn't be understated but um but
about how best to reach people about how
to do activism about how to speak to
people's hearts and and not to fight
in the 80s when she was doing her work
when she was trying to reach the
research uh scientists and try to
convince them to change what she
ultimately did
she faced so much opposition from the
environmental groups from animal rights
activists they were they picketed her
and they were screaming things at her
how dare you uh talk to the oil
companies how dare you talk to the
research uh companies you know this is
they're the enemy and that's
we talked about this today but like so
much of i think what's wrong with social
media and the way we've become so
tribalized is because of that ideas like
they're bad we're good and you just kind
of yell at each other
and that doesn't lead to progress no
progress it's just
we were talking about this recently was
it um god who who was it with louis
anderson maybe that
um
that he lacks any cynicism and and
that's
really rare for uh last week yeah for a
comedian um yeah but she seems similar
like
she
her podcast name hope cast i think for a
reason because she seems very
hopeful and oh jeff corwin too yeah how
he still in the face of all this
troubling uh news and information that
he has right he's still hopeful and
positive and thinks that we can all make
a difference and i admire her
positivity i
i wish i was less cynical because i feel
like oh there's just not enough people
like her in the world today to be able
to make a difference if more people were
like her then i genuinely believe i know
could save this planet but then for all
the
people like her or even close to her
because who's really like her let's face
it um but even the people who admire her
and have similar you know lean that way
then you see
that's why when someone throws i heard
zach alfenac is talking about this when
and it comforted me to hear how much he
hated this too when you see somebody
throw trash out their window something
as simple as that like
you know an act like that just throw
something on the outside like
there's something so upsetting about
that i think i think there's some sort
of like equation between that how
upsetting that is and the beauty that
you can find in the world jane goodall
does i know it's even i i feel the same
you don't both have to dislike litterers
but there is something i've always been
really bothered by people who literally
yeah some sort of deep i mean and and
it's and it's it's the exact opposite
like you said of her when she she said
when you borrow something like we're
borrowing this earth this planet and
when you borrow something you have to
give it back
in this case she thinks we should be
giving it to the next generation but
she said we're stealing it and that's
how i feel about litterers it's people
who feel entitled to this is mine and
i've taken this and i don't care about
what's happening next well she touched
on this and we inherited it from our we
took it or borrowed it or we're
borrowing it from our parents generation
and and that's why that little activist
what's her name the environmental
correctness
greater tune
of dance not fantastic um
she i think that's why her anger is sort
of like justified you know because she
seems to have a lot of like how dare you
she's like yeah that kind of she was an
answer rather a question on jeopardy the
other night and when katie couric was
guest hosting and
someone sorry this is uh
just reminded me of it and she
the contestant said um
said greta thundberg and katie couric
really shamed her for pronouncing it
thunberg she was like it's toonberg but
we'll accept thundberg oh really it was
a really shamey moment
front of the show okay yes yes hopefully
listening
uh but katie um twittenberg oh that's uh
i wish i had seen tat
stupids
uh you know you were talking about hope
like how can she have this hope you know
i'm thinking about her documentary now
and she she mentioned them a lot in the
context of
hope and
when we would talk i would ask her i
think i asked her that like how can you
do she mentioned roots and shoots a
couple times and um and when you see
the work that they do and when you see
like the kids that are moved and
inspired by
dr jane goodall um in the roots and
shoots program it kind of makes sense
how she is able to have this sort of
hope because the next generation some of
these kids are exceptional and they've
been and they're really like picking up
the torch for her jane's work and it
must be something that she herself is
inspired by and moved by because
you know she talks about her own
mortality a lot on in the documentary
and she must be there must be some sort
of
there's got to be an awareness of okay
my work is going to continue and she
believes so strongly in her work
to the point where it sacrificed so much
on its behalf that it must be really
comforting to know that you're these
kids these younger people are taking up
uh maybe that maybe that's what it comes
down to then that if you believe in
something enough
like she does like jeff corman does yeah
then like if you believe something is
important enough then um you must just
be able to
ignore any
cynical urges that you
might feel you know because it's like
saving the planet saving chimpanzees is
is so important that you just have to
like keep going forward and
do whatever you can do to uh
alleviate the problem and you certainly
can't dwell on
i guess that's kind of solipsistic to
dwell on your own mortality too much
like to like
worry too much about your own existence
ending and we were talking about that
the other day how like you've been
getting um you feel the older you get
you feel
you're still afraid of dying and like
you still don't want to but like you
were less
concerned about death i did say that
yeah and it was it was interesting
because your reason was well life
becomes less
just slightly less enjoyable enjoyable
as your body shuts down you can't
process certain things as well and you
can't do as much as you could your body
doesn't feel as good
you guys you introduce that and um and
that occurred to me uh
in the context of jane when she was
talking about it was so sad um when she
was talking about being able to commune
with the with the chimps and
and i said well you must be dying to get
back there you know um yeah that was
that was sad and she said well it's not
the same i can't you know climb
she just can't do the way she used to
and it seems like it was a source of so
much joy and happiness in her life it is
sad to um i was watching an episode of
cobra kai last night and
wait but sorry to just finish i thought
like well
perhaps there's a part of her that
thinks because she does seem so
spiritual especially about gambi and um
and that maybe when she's when she's
left this
existence
she'll be able to do that again you know
maybe i thought that'd be cool yeah
sorry you were watching that'd be nice
uh
no well daniel returns to okinawa to the
village spoiler uh well you should be
caught up it's been out for a while and
he realizes that this village that was
so um
untouched or not very touched when he
was a teenager is now full of it's like
a strip mall and there's all these big
corporations there and it really saddens
them and uh
and that's just what's happening all
over the world wow i'm surprised it's
good for you to compare jane goodall to
daniel larusso
by the way also a friend of the show
yeah i know ralph i like to tie things
together yeah um
well uh
god we are just so
grateful to you better yeah um i'm
shocked she doesn't use emojis
that was one of the funniest lighting
rounds because she didn't
she truly i know you know a lot of
people are like oh i don't they kind of
feign like
but she and i really believe that she
does i'm so glad you didn't ask her what
her favorite movie sequel was there
would have been a very long pause
she's just a dozen i know i couldn't i
went through the i did the math like as
quickly as i could i was like there's no
way and even saying to her because you
forget she's by the way she's so she's
so beautiful and like there's something
so angelic about her that you sort of
she's like ageless that you forget i
forgot that she grew up during a time
and in a socioeconomic way that she
just didn't absorb any of that stuff any
like movies or tv or she grew up in the
40s during the war
and i realized that as i said it like
what movie you know i forget what it is
she also wasn't who's your favorite
golden girl she also when she talks
about observing squirrels and worms and
you know these creatures as a kid
that's
what she cared about yeah and that's
what she still cares about you know
she's
she's not someone who
cares about i know things like movies
and i know she really has like a uh such
a specific
passion you know this is i don't know
how to say this without sounding
uh i don't know this might be weird but
talking to her and at the end when i was
like you know let me know if there's
anything i i would like follow her
and you were like you were like um if
you need anything you're
the subject's being like can i please
come on a trip with you and play with
monkeys i mean and just to do the
worksheet that she what she's doing is
the most important thing for the world
like i don't want to be a disciple that
i would i would i can understand how
people follow
you know like jesus
wow she's she's a messiah-like figure to
me whoa you just went next level well
think about it i mean how does it get
more in terms of a cause and in terms of
how
how you connect with people and
i i don't know how it gets any more
jesus-like than that is that is that
offensive to
christians uh
it might be it should not be i i hold
her in the highest christ like christ
just christ like yeah i i still think
you you are defensive
no you say christ like someone's christ
i don't think so
i mean
she is just i think it's what i believe
you might start start to wade into
insulting territory if you put her on
par with christ
right
okay but to say someone is christ-like
then i i think you're giving credit
to
christ and while also describing the
goodness of someone i would follow her
i'd be a disciple i'd be a good artist
like i really want to do more with that
roots and shoots program it seems like
the most essential and you don't think
it's
a little selfish because you just want
to play with monkeys it is a little
selfish part of it is that i'm sure but
i'm not i swear i'm not like i want to
do stuff with the the communities that
she goes into hey
i did it i know yeah you made me you
want me to do it again no i'm not gonna
push my luck
um but the communities that she goes
into
uh i would love that just
she's just so inspiring okay
i know you don't have to sell me on her
yeah how cool i i'd go on a trip with
her it was one of my uh favorite moments
was when she just this is selfish when
she was like please call me jane and
then you proceeded to call her doctor
goodall again i did yeah i did yeah just
once oh
i i it was hard because the respect that
i have um
yeah jane had jane and then when you
asked her if she's able to zoom with
chimps and she was like no
yeah oh my god that's right
and then
and then she said that in theory you
could yeah yeah and i was like
um
jane has anything to do with tarzan
that's what that that was
uh surprising when she left the movie
that when she
uh when she admitted that tarzan was
this single thing that inspired her no i
need to go do what she did well in the
documentary she said she was also very
inspired she carried so sweet she
carries a copy her copy as a from a
childhood of um dr doolittle around with
her and i remember she was flipping
through it and we had the same not this
i don't know if it's the same it was the
same illustrations i don't know if it
was the same exact year but
similar enough that they had the same
illustrations i remembered them i loved
that book that is weird that her name is
jane i guess it's just a coincidence
unless you changed it i don't think she
changed it did you appreciate herself
with the chimps maybe she liked
tarzan
even more because of jane maybe maybe
that drew her towards
maybe the book the book which led to
then you think about like that naming a
kid could be that influential in their
lives
interesting it's like
i i wonder if um because that book was
so in fact it was so instrumental and
she was so important to her that she
left the movie how cool was that and
cool but like interesting that uh she
because she was she cried because the
image on screen was so dissimilar to the
one in her imagination of tarzan and
then i
re-listening to it i was like
i
was curious i wish i had asked her what
her image
sorry what her image of tarzan was you
know
in her head who did he look like if not
johnny weissmuller
she uh she mentioned robert redford and
she was like i don't even know people
like i guess wrapping red food but i
mean rob redford is still
alive but it's funny to use him as an
example of an actor who it's like kind
of current
i know like um
at least she knew of him but um i and
i'm sure their paths had crossed because
they're both he does
work that's like yeah he's a good person
as well yeah maybe future guests of the
show that'd be cool let's read a letter
okay here we go here is a letter uh this
is from
joe dean
joe dean joe dean jody
dean have you ever heard of a joe dean
how do you spell it jay oh
would it matter have you heard of any
joe dean spelled anyway no but i'm
wondering if you're pronouncing it wrong
oh
oh j-o-d-e-a-n
wait sorry one more time j-o-d-e-a-n
joe day-in
champagne shoot shook joe dane
cool name yeah cool name joe dean
it is a cool name subject ed was my
favorite show ever three exclamation
points hello justin and christian i just
have to get this out of the way i'm
going to fangirl for a minute i've loved
you since ed now
it was my favorite show maybe of all
time
i loved the unique concept of the show
and the interpersonal relationships that
the characters portrayed i wish it would
come to netflix or some other streaming
service so i could watch it all over
again i do too i'd like to see some of
those episodes what a fun experience
you'd like to fangirl out yeah i'd like
to fangirl over tom's and julie's
performance i wish it would come to
netflix or something oh i said that also
going the distance is one of my favorite
rom-coms also in fact i just watched it
again last month i also loved you on new
girl ah there's a lot of fan growing
this is great this is great for me
i wish your role would have lasted
longer needless to say
you can tell and that's really sweet
jodeen thank you she said needless to
say this is embarrassing for me which is
why i'm stumbling through it i'm sorry
needless to say you can tell i'm a big
big fan thank you joe dean i learned
from listening to dax that you had a
podcast oh thanks again to dax i almost
wrecked my car i got so excited oh i'm
glad you didn't i'm in the process of
binge listening to every episode luckily
i have an hour commute to and from work
so i have plenty of time to listen my
favorite episodes are the ones where you
interview your friends like jerry
o'connell hey jerry hope he's listening
jake johnson lamorne and max just to
name a few i hope they're all listening
i just want to say thank you for having
a podcast that one makes me pee my pants
laughing two is free of political talk
mostly
three
makes me love my siblings more hearing
your relationship with your brother wow
very nice joe dean thanks for making my
drive to and from work two of my
favorite parts of the day can you guys
answer my would you rather yes okay back
to would you rather's
number one
would you rather never be able to listen
to music ever again or never be able to
watch a movie ever again we've done this
one before and here's the tricky part of
this music and movies yep so you'd have
to like so for those part i mean how do
you eliminate music from movies you
wouldn't i i would argue that the music
you get to listen to in movies is not
nearly the same as
just listening to music regularly
because it's usually
either part of the score of the movie or
it's like there's a part of a song
during a montage or something it's such
a tease in terms of
listening to it it's not really
listening to music yeah it's not like
putting on yeah it's not like a
different song really but it but you'd
still get quite a fix of me i'm thinking
about some of the great some of my
favorite movies like breakfast club or
lost boys there's that great music that
you'll get that's true that's the
mohicans yeah i would say
and this might be a [ __ ] answer but
i would say i would
get rid of movies because there's so
much great tv
now um [ __ ] i think that should
probably go
hand in hand with a
movie i think the older i get
i aspire to um
listen to more music yeah and watch more
of a music and and avoid screens more in
general yeah so i think my um right now
i value movies more probably but i
aspire
to value music more in my older age does
that make sense it does
so i would get rid of movies i think
especially like you said if you could
watch some tv like if i could watch
seinfeld and practice jokers and dr jane
goodall documentaries exactly and no
movies i would definitely take but music
like what music can do to you like how
can i know movies can move you obviously
and inspire you but there's something
different about what music can do to the
soul and it's a much more personal
experience yes for me for me personally
but uh it's a little bit like
what jane said about uh watching that
tarzan for the first time it's like
it it doesn't require nearly as much of
your imagination right in a weird way i
think music is just more important
mm-hmm
to me yeah for me yeah yeah and like
i've had near spiritual if not spiritual
full you know both have to have
spiritual moments for music
thinking of like the sasquatch festival
oh god yeah listening to it i've never
had that i've loved movies i've loved
movies
and been so like stirred stirred by them
but music does something different
number two the second would you rather
would you rather be the star in the
biggest longest running hit tv show of
all time but never be able to be in a
movie again or would you rather be the
star of the biggest grossing movie of
all time that becomes a classic that
people watch for the next 30 years but
never be able to appear in another role
in front of the camera ever again that's
easy oh yeah the first one first one for
sure because it's just ego
uh choosing the second one would just be
ego exactly exactly like i just want to
be celebrated for this one thing exactly
that's a no-brainer it's like but i
don't get to do the thing i love to do
because then you can tell but even with
the tv show you would probably get tired
of being on the same tv show for 15
years you know i think about that
sometimes because a friend of mine was
just talking about how much they love uh
su law order suv and svu oh svu
yeah um
and i thought about and how chris miller
we were talking about chris maloney and
marisha marishka or tay
and i thought
both very good actors but i was like
wondering if they are sick of doing that
show
chris maloney i know left the show for a
while and like did other things but like
i would suspect they're not because
they're still doing it
and i think at this point uh-huh it's up
to them of course that's true they don't
need to do it it's not you know when you
do a show you have to sign what a
six-year contract usually yeah but
beyond that you get to renegotiate and
have more control over i know i guess
i'm just especially a show like that
it's called a procedural show like that
it's like you're wired a little
differently i'm wired a little i need
more spice yes
but but like look not to [ __ ] on that
you're just different different yeah
like i don't know if you could as much
as i admire that they're doing that as
much as you love chimpanzees i know i
don't know if you could sit for seven or
eight months in the wild waiting for
them to get closer to you i know so when
i say i want to be your disciple like
i'm sure that would be
that kind of work would would be
involved in being her disciple is like
cons it's commitment like the way she
could she's committed her life he put
you to work for a while like mr miyagi
did with daniel larusso can you tell
i've been watching a lot of cobra kai
what season are you on three oh how many
seasons are there four right i think
there's four oh i wanna watch it it's
good it's really fun yeah i know i've
been seeing like little um
moments that it's very nostalgic
nostalgia vibes i like nostalgia vibes
back to joe dean again thanks for
getting me through this year by being
who you guys are take care show dean
shook
baby chuck um
oh shucks
she probably hears that a lot i wonder
what she hears more is my question to
jodi and chuck if she hears josh shucks
or jody jody
i have a feeling if i had to guess put
money on it i would guess
uh
as long as it's in fact pronounced
jodine
i would guess she gets uh
jodie jodie more
maybe or or maybe even what the shock
especially lately because i feel like
dolly parton has had a real risk
yeah you both have to think that dolly
parton has had a resurgence in the last
few years she has yeah um
but you know now i think it might be sh
shook uh because remember that crook you
shook me all night long oh yeah she
might get that she might well thanks
jodine and uh thanks to if there's other
joe dean's listening
what do you think the odds are of that
thank you for writing in and for your
very nice email and if you guys would
like to write in our email is life is
short at wondery.com and thank you again
to
our first dame hopefully not our last
but um definitely our first
and our most uh certainly our most
christ-like figure the brilliant
dr jane goodall the yes and
kind and so good for the world we're so
grateful that she uh graced us with her
presence i know that's like uh i don't
know if i've ever used that so
appropriately she graced us she sure did
her presence here brought grace to the
show and her
presence in the world brings grace to
the earth so thanks to her and um if you
want to check out what she check check
out what she's up to uh such important
things roots and shoots
and takara uh and what the jane goodall
institute continues to do uh like she
said it just takes two people to want to
change things and um get involved so
thank you to her and uh to everyone
listening talk to you next
week life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by one
megan monaco the senior producer here is
michelle miesh lan
and audio engineer is sergio enrique
and executive producer oriole skills the
one who has decided to use marshall
for wondering
thank you everyone
[Music]
he's like two feet away from oprah
and he's like
that's true
that's true it's like shut up you play
with them without doing the clucking
noises but she's like she's doing he's
never had to worry about interrupting
anything right no one's ever been like
except for like the queen or his brother
maybe right maybe but nobody did that to
his brother so no one's ever been like
now he's in the outside world he's
he's like taking the power back
maybe he's like i'll i'll do i can do
whatever i want yeah no one ever say
because like there's no one above
her right oprah's shirt above him i mean
she is
yeah he doesn't think so right he just
thinks like the queen charles and
william are above him
so when they're not around he probably
acts like i can do anything i want yeah
cause he definitely subscribed to the
hierarchy because he was like he said to
her
she's like i thought it was just like
your grandmother like it told you it's
like your grandmother goes it's the
queen
yeah he's like it's the queen
you're curtsy for the queen
she's the queen first and my
grandmother's
second wait let's see who [ __ ]
you